مشاهدينا مرحبا بكم في هذه النافذه
الانسانيه الخاصه نناقش فيها وصف المقرره
الامميه لحقوق الانسان بالاراضي
الفلسطينيه فرانشيسكا البانيز ما تفعله
اسرائيل بالفلسطينيين في غزه بانه يمثل
اهوال القرن الحادي والعشر وان الصمط
الغربي يتحول الى تواطؤ ستكون معنا
المقرره الامميه لحقوق الانسان بالاراضي
الفلسطينيه فرانشيسكا البنز للحديث عن هذا
التوصيف وكيف ترى ما يجري من عدوان
اسرائيلي على قطاع غزه واهله في البدايه
نذكر بعدد الشهداء في اليوم
الث3 للحرب الاسرائيليه على قطاع غزه
وزاره الصحه في غزه قالت ان عدد الشهداء
ارتفع الى
217 بينهم
8800 طفل اضافه الى 6000
و300 امراه بينما وصل عدد الجرحى الى
و915 منذ السابع من اكتوبر
الماضي هناك ايضا 7000 مفقود تحت الانقاض
او مصيرهم مجهول 70% من المفقودين هم من
الاطفال
والنساء اذا من مدينه
اريانوس
البنز المقرره الامميه لحقوق الانسان في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه مرحبا بك سيده
فرانشيسكا و لماذا وصفت ما يجري في قطاع
غزه بانه يمثل اهوال القرن الحادي
والعشر حلو حسن حسن كما تعلم نعم انا
كنت كنت استاذ في القانون الدولي والتقيت
باحدهم من هذا التخصص وهذا الشخص علق على
قله وجود او عدم وجود رد متماسك من
المجتمع الدولي خاصه المختصين بالجانب
القانوني اذ انه يلتزمون الصمت امام هذه
البشعات بشاعات الاهواء التي في هذا
القرن بالنسبه ان تقوم باسرائيل
غادر ما يسمى بالقانون الدولي منذ عقود
فاسرائيل ارتكبت الكثير من الجرائم ضد
الفلسطينيين وبشكل خاص الفلسطينيين في غزه
في
الماضي والان يظهرون العالم شيئا اكبر رعب
كبير فهذا وصل الى مستوى
مستوى القتل الجماعي وحمله اباده كامله
كما ذكرتم فهناك حول 20 الى 30 الف شخص
قتلوا واضافه لان اضافه الى 21000 الذين
فعلا جرى كتابات تقارير عن عن قتلهم هناك
ايضا سبع الى 9000 شخص ما زالوا مفقودين
وعلى الارجح هم
تحت ركام المباني وان تدمير كل البنى
التحتيه المدنيه يعتبر والذي هو مهم جدا
لبقاء الناس على الحياه وانظر لمستشفيات
كيف انها دمرت تماما هناك هناك الف هناك
الف
طفل جرتج عمليات لهم دون تخدير
لانه يمنعون وصول الماده المخدره وهذا
يعكس مدى قساوه ولا يمكن افكر باي نوع من
هذه القساوه والشده في زمننا هذا الذي
يهدف الى الحاق الضر والان لذلك هذا امر
وحشي وانا اتفق مع هذا القول طيب وصفت
الامر ايضا بانه اباده
جماعيه بوصف القانون الدولي هل هناك ما
يمكن ان يستند اليه قانونا فيما لو ذهبت
الامور الى اروقه المحاكم الدوليه لو سمح
الوضع الدولي بذلك هل هناك ما يدعم هذا
التوصيف او هذا الاتهام بال باده الجماعيه
التي ترتكبها اسرائيل ضد الفلسطينيين في
قطاع
غزه نعم نعم ليس هناك ضروره ان يكون
لدينا محكمه موجوده لنعرف هل ان اسرائيل
وما تقوم به لابد ان يتوقف لان منجر
اتفاقيه او معاهده الاباده الجماعيه عند
هناك نيه واضحه تدمير شعب كامل و عن طريق
القتل وعن طريق
اعمال وضع ضغوط نفسيه والصدمات النفسيه
وبدنيه كبيره على الناس او خلق ظروف قد
تؤدي بان جعل حياه البشر غير ممكنه
وبالتالي هذا هذا يعني هناك ما هناك خطر
حصول اباده جماعيه وهذا الذي يطلق عمليه
التزام بالقانون الدولي على الدول بان
تتدخل ان تمنع
فهذا التزام في القانون الدولي قبل
التنشيط المحاكم للتحقيق
ومحاكمه من يقومون بهذه الاعمال هناك
التزام بايقاف عمليه الاباده الجماعيه
عندما هناك خطر ارتكابها وهذا الخطر فعلا
يزداد يزداد مره بعد اخرى واصبح دليل
واضح ان هناك اباده جماعيه مستمره
وتزداد وطبعا هناك بعض الدول بعض الاطراف
السياسيه ودول
الاعضاء يقولون ك لا يرد استخدام هذه
الكلمه اللي يقولون هذا هذا السياسي هذا
ليس بشيء سياسي هذا هذا
مصطح قانوني فهذه جريمه ولكن اليوم اخيرا
فان دوله جنوب
افريقيا ادانت ما تقوم به اسرائيل لانها
تق هذا ما يقوم به عمل اباده جماعيه وبدات
باطلاق الاجراءات الرسميه لوصول الى محكم
العداله الدوليه توصل الى قرار
ملزم لاصدار قرار هناك خطر باباده جماعيه
وهذا امر لا يمكن تجنبه بسهوله وهل ما
قامت به جنوب افريقيا وما ذكرتيه في هذا
المجال برايك يمكن ان يصل الى
نهاياته خصوصا وانك ذكرتي بان ما يحصل
انما يحصل بتواطئ غربي وصمت غربي وقبول
غربي
اعتقد ان المسؤوليه
الرئيسيه هي تقع على عاتق الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والعالم الغربي لان
الولايات المتحده هي التي تقوم بمنع
الجهود جهود دول الاخرى التي بشكل واضح
كان دائما الى جانب اسرائيل ولكن بمر
الوقت بداوا يخففوا
غيروا موقفهم ازاع
اسرائيل فيما يتعلق باسرائيل لكن الولايات
المتحده هي التي تمنع مره بعد
اخرى مجلس الامن و اي قرار فيها الذي يمكن
لاصدار ما نحتاجه الى وقف اطلاق نار شكرا
لك وعذرا للمقاطعه لانتهاء الوقت السيده
فرانشيسكا البانيز المقرره
الامميه للاراضي الفلسطينيه شكرا جزيلا لك